en este diagrama tenemos dos arcos que
están centrados en el punto p pueden
imaginarse este arco como si fuera una
parte de una circunferencia más o menos
así algo así y el arco más grande este
verde es parte de otra circunferencia
que también es más grande pero también
tiene centro en el punto p más o menos
así
desconocemos el valor de este ángulo
pero conocemos las longitudes de los
radios de este círculo azul o de este
arco azul y del arco verde así que
podemos encontrar una forma de calcular
la longitud del arco ave
entre la longitud
del arco cede
podemos encontrar esta proporción en la
longitud de estos dos arcos pausa en el
vídeo y traten de pensar en ello no nos
dieron el ángulo medido en radiales o en
grados pero imaginemos que son x
radiales x
radiales ya vimos que una manera de
pensar en la medida de un ángulo en
radiales es que esto es un conteo del
número de longitud del arco que se
intersecta al ángulo en términos de los
radios si este ángulo mide x radiales
entonces quiere decir que este arco
serán x radios de largo el arco ave
tiene un radio de 5 unidades este arco
tiene una longitud de 5 x x 5 por el
radio y x por la medida en radiales del
ángulo que no lo conozco pero le pongo x
mide 5 x de largo y la misma lógica
aplica para el arco más grande para el
verde aquí tenemos un radio de 9
5 de este y 4 de este pedacito 5 4 al 9
y es el mismo ángulo de x radiales así
que este arco de acá va a medir el radio
9 por el valor del ángulo x en radiales
así que cuál es la proporción entre el
arco más pequeño y el arco más grande
pues vamos a sustituir estos valores
aquí así que la longitud del arco ave es
igual a 5x y la longitud del arco cde es
9 x
simplificamos a esto las equis se van y
nos queda que la proporción es de 5 a 9
ahora imaginemos que alguien nos dice
bueno eso está muy bien pudimos
encontrar la proporción pero digamos que
nos dan la longitud del arco del arco a
ver nos dicen que la longitud del arco
ave es igual a 25 a 8 si nos dan esto
que podemos averiguar pues de hecho
podemos encontrar todos los demás
valores podemos encontrar el ángulo en
radiales y también la longitud del arco
ce de los invitó de nuevo a que pausa en
el vídeo y piensen en esto pues pasemos
a calcular los ya sabemos que este arco
ave es igual a 5x así que este 25
entre 8 es igual a 5x dividimos ambos
lados entre 5 y nos queda que x es igual
a 5 octavos así que la medida de este
ángulo es de 5 octavos de radiales cuál
será la medida del arco se de
queremos que el arco se dé es igual a 9
x y encontramos x esto va a ser igual a
9 por 5 octavos 9 por 5 45 es igual a 45
octavos